[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
tous nous sommes lundi 1er avril et ses
touches femmes au quotidien merci d'être
avec nous dans un instant on recevra le
petit virtuose de la flûte électronique
michel stroganoff qui sera avec nous
dans un instant michel qui a fait un
carton aux grilles qui serait avec nous
bien sûr dans quelques instants c'est la
révélation vous le savez hongroise de
flûte électronique on aura également
d'ailleurs c'est un instrument qui a
fait parler de lui en savent attendus ou
pas parler doivent tout électrique
on aurait il de vos allées là
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
on discutera également du bric site pour
la 35e semaine et nos chroniqueurs
stagiaires bien sûr sont allés enquêter
sur le très controversé
brian fellous bien sortir son livre mon
régime sans viande sans poisson sans
légumes et sans eau
bref je mange des pierres et je suis
bien dans ma peau on aura tout à l'heure
avec j'ai pas de photo de brian son look
et j'ai envie de dire où il fait beau
sur le ciel de paris on va regarder quel
temps il fait sur la capitale quand même
bien sûr on n'a pas les images puisque
nous sommes d'eau touche pas à mon poste
c'est pas
[Applaudissements]
ouais
c'est jean marc morandini qui avait
lancé ce poisson d'avril voilà que ce
serait voilà on échange mais pas son
troisième marché chez moi pour l'instant
c'est pas l'ordre du jour non sait
jamais ça peut arriver l'année prochaine
pour la dixième saison
[Applaudissements]